out of your mind here's the debate
you're upset
[Music]
all right folks we are live episode
number 167 today with the crew adam
sosnick uh vinnie o'shanna and jedediah
biela in the house we got a lot of
topics to cover
we may get a call in from a mayor pro
temp
i love the program
everything is temporary from a uh from
west hollywood's uh mayor who apparently
they just actually defunded the police
yeah they just actually defunded the
police and their strategy is to have the
local civilians armed to protect the
city nice that's why vinnie moved out of
l.a
which by the way isn't that a
conservative philosophy yeah exactly
what i'm saying you want a militia
but you realize how weird that is if you
defund the police to get people in west
hollywood civilians to have guns to be
trained to protect the city
got to be like the complete opposite of
progressive philosophy and they're
called safety ambassadors and in l.a in
like north hollywood where i live
they're just people with yellow shirts
on bikes no guns no nothing oh no guns
no guns they just talked to you and bro
if this is happening it was was
hollywood it's going to be a bunch of
people like if somebody's about to shoot
somebody they're going to go hey stop
and then that's it we're not going to
switch hollywood where all the is that
the game west hollywood is a it's a yeah
it's dude when people say west hollywood
is the manners what's the wilton
mountain manners yeah but it's wilton
manors times ten times yeah yeah but it
is what it is are those handcuffs
just safety guys guys stop sorry and
just people are gonna leave like no
that's not you're gonna confuse people
you're gonna think you came here from la
like if you want that position to be
yours you sound too natural but you
didn't
i did that's the whole thing
all right so listen topics topics topics
what we got today we got a lot of things
to cover
retirement savers lost three trillion
dollars
in the stock market yeah allegedly they
lost three trillion dollars this is
yahoo news uh story
a uh story came out for marky dwight
saying it's now officially more
expensive to own a home than to rent a
home so maybe it's more
at a time where this may not be a
message that people want to hear in real
estate but this story came out from
market watch and the real deal instagram
account actually shared this next
twitter suspends
jordan peterson after he tweets uh at
ellen page just had her breasts removed
and he got suspended forward sir it's
elliot page please did i say well it
used to be ellen don't don't know it's
elliott now it's ellie what does this
story say ellen page i'm just i'm just
letting you know that's all that's
scroll back oh my gosh now it's elliott
before the transformation that's yeah
yeah that was okay all right next by the
way this one's interesting here fcc
commissioner urges tick tock
to be removed from apple
google stores over unacceptable national
security risk weird very weird wasn't
there uh there's some orange guy that
was shouting about this three or four
years yeah he was but he vaguely
remembered that he's offensive listen
which is not acceptable this next story
this next story is a little wild one uh
trans skateboarder
who won first prize against teen in a is
a combat vet dad who has rejected who
was rejected from olympics with three
kids
my mind just hurt trying to
wrestle with that that's not a satire
story it's not babylon b that's not that
this is a real story that's taking place
uh by the way let me give you another
statistic here that's pretty concerning
for a
uh state imagine if a company lost 21
billion dollars in revenues what that
would mean 21 billion dollars in
revenues if you count that for ebitda
time say 15 times that's 300 billion
dollars in valuation you lost well that
company is called new york new york lost
21 billion in income from the irs this
is irs revenue they lost
in uh 2021. uh another story is a board
ape themed restaurant who will no longer
accept crypto payment okay it the whole
idea is what's the crypto but they're
not gonna be exactly the story hurts my
mind almost as much as the the trans
skateboarder
same amount welcome to 2020 this next
story may have some i think we may get
into this one nbc reporter birthing
people not getting abortions will hurt
the economy okay could put there could
be actually a good argument for that we
can talk about that
i just got laid off for my dream job at
tesla without warning i feel like my job
my life got uprooted so a billionaire
could save some money okay
okay why billionaire ken griffin is
moving citadel headquarters to miami
from chicago uh riots and employees
stabbed and the attempted hijacking of
his own car so he finally says i'm
leaving chicago i'm going down here
pennsylvania considers welfare reform to
keep food stamps from going to ready
dead recipient true story i'm going to
dead recipients howard's turn may run
for office okay
and then obviously in upscale west
hollywood votes to defund sheriff's
department which we talked about at the
beginning so having said that let's see
which story we want to get into first
can i can i make a request yes go
forward before we get into stories
topical events yeah one of the four of
us just came back from
the most expensive place in the world
and i'd be remiss if we didn't at least
cover the fact that you someone on the
panel was in monaco
hanging with sheiks and princesses and
that type of life so i'm just throwing
that out there i don't know if it was
vinnie jedidiah
someone might want to just it was not me
trust me i was i was in the office the
whole time okay so uh uh yeah we were
monica we took 120 of our guys to paris
and monaco we had a great time we put
them at the wyndham in paris and then we
took them to monaco at the fairmont
nikki beach
some of our guys
took uh
rides down to italy someone to camp
someone to saint tropez we took a
helicopter ride from monaco to centro
pay which is ridiculous on the way back
we're 30 minutes late
so the the helicopter we have to go to
the airport which is in saint tropez the
guy just flies it into someone's
backyard no joke
you got the story yeah he flies it into
someone's backyard
no joke he flies it into someone's back
you're like this is a joke it's not
saint tropez we get in this guy's
backyard we get in the helicopter we
come to monaco amazing well everybody in
san jose has a helicopter landing pad in
their backyard below talking about
nobody complaining they all just like by
the way
you know what's the best thing about
monaco here's the best thing about
monaco the best thing about monaco why i
love it there
nobody gives a [ __ ] how successful and
famous you are that's important because
just a minute ago you know billionaire
sat there a minute ago you know elon was
there a minute ago a prince was there
so if you are this like famous
instagrammer or you're this youtuber or
this millionaire no one needs a [ __ ]
so when it's kind of like do you know
who i am sir the president and the prime
minister was just here before you no
matter who you are you're probably not
more actually i know exactly who you are
and that's why i'm treating you like
yeah because you're only worth 100
million but i will just guess worth 100
but i will tell you guys i will tell you
guys a crazy story about monica what
happened one of our guys renee dalila
raised shout out to those guys their
their five-year-old kid i believe
had a 105 fever and it's 3 30 in the
morning they come back from the casino
monte carlo casino and they come back
they're like oh shoot our son's got a
105 fever they come downstairs to
concierge concierge calls uh emerge you
know all the places yeah pharmacies
close everybody's closed the cop shows
up no joke monaco pd shows up picks them
up
takes them and calls the uh the uh well
what he called surgeon pharmacy brings
the doctor in at 3 30 4 00 in the
morning they open up they look at the
kid they give him the medication and
then the cops bring him back in another
one of our guys who was a former nfl
player cowboys guy he played under drew
bledsoe and roma during that era wow he
jumps in the ocean they're on a yacht
they're going out and his butt gets hit
by the propeller oh my god listen
i'm not even kidding
he's gotta cut this big tj okay
he's gotta cut this big
they come they take him yeah they you
know stitch him up 15 stitches and he's
bleeding in the ocean by the way that's
a shark that's shot yeah it's like shark
food but uh he went back they came they
stitched them up no question no do you
have a health insurance card nothing
boom went away that's monaco for you by
the way the highest life expectancy in
the world the average person there lives
up to 89 and a half yeah they're rich
they're chilling and insurance is great
tax haven
treatment is incredible we went to le
louis uh 15 to have dinner there the
dinner we went there monday night we
went there friday night we took ten of
our guys on friday night it's a
five-hour dinner when you go
it's my kind of dinner yeah it's five
hour dinner and the stuff that they did
they brought a
pigeon they brought a pitch and they're
like i said so this is a good job
you know what he's saying
he says jennifer's like i'm sorry what
did he just say
it says it's it's is this chicken no
it's a pigeon yeah so yeah i'm like i
don't know what he's saying babe see the
guy it's a pigeon
it's like it's a real pigeon this is a
pigeon so okay let me try i've never
eaten a pigeon but was it good yeah no
it wasn't it's like duck-ish it tastes
like duck listen if you like duck if you
like pigeon it's a partly like it's a
chicken with an attitude because when
you eat it you have to your teeth are
gonna get a workout but okay for those
of us that have been following or pbd
podcasts for two years now you gotta
tell us if you had the lobster roll it
was your favorite lobster roll
so that hotel
was shut down for renovations
we went to the annex in can
which uh we listen it's our favorite
place in the world it's my favorite
place in the world when i go there's
just a different kind of a treatment it
was tom's 68th birthday oh i saw that
for his birthday i got a the flag that
santa drove when he won in brazil
signed by senator you should have seen
his reaction crying
and uh got him a nice uh rolex white
gold watch and i got him the senna he
got the watch he goes like this oh cool
oh my god
what what the hell yeah he had like zero
interest for the watch but he was so
excited but anyways we had a very good
time he turned sixty six zero birthday
biz doc said he died he doesn't even
look it by the way but he did turn 60 uh
and we had a good time there and some
some and we were working i'll tell you
after a lot of stuff what's going on uh
but it's exciting time how was paris by
the way because we just skipped right
over paris we just went right to monaco
we went straight to monaco we didn't go
to paris our guys went to paris we were
at monaco ourselves and uh well out of
150 people only a fever and a butt cut
that's not that it's not about nobody's
like nobody died nobody was partying do
you find it relaxing or is it kind of
like i don't know i always think of
places like that and i'm like i don't is
it stuffy do you feel like you always
have to be this or be that or is it
super chill because everyone's in the
same boat
it's whatever you want it to be okay
first time you go to be intimidating
yeah first time you go it'll be
intimidating because
it's the only place in the world that
nobody gives a crap what you drive what
kind of clothes you got on everybody
dresses nice a lambo is a taxi wow so if
you drive a lambo here you're like oh my
gosh i got a lambo over there it's a
taxi a road source is a taxi like okay
you know 50 rolls royces you see
everything paganis you see everything
there it's not a big deal if you wanted
to buy a two-bedroom
condo underwater in monaco you ready how
about 30. well how much 30 million
bedroom 2-bedroom 30 million bucks in
monaco same price
there must be a stat for like uh uber
drivers or whatever all the like valet
guys those guys must be paid like they
must be the richest in the 20 bucks a
minute not no joke it's 20 bucks
when you went from one yeah like duper
over there like let's go
can you imagine like a cast so what'd
you make last year 380 how much did you
keep five grand
what what is the tax situation in monaco
i i don't know exactly what the tax
situation is but it is known as a tax
haven that's what morocco is known for i
don't know the exact details but it is
known as a tax savings so if you're
thinking about moving there it's a great
place
i wonder what kind of incentives they
give like you know
in in florida a lot of people move to
puerto rico because it's like it's close
to florida close to miami puerto rico
four percent income tax when you said
they brought a pigeon to the table i
don't know why i felt like the actual
bird and you get to go no i'm like okay
and just let it go
like no i want that one
they don't bring a pigeon to the table
so first of all it's not that great
listen this is this i've had it i can't
stand butter i haven't really i'm a
cheese person i'm not a butter person
except if i'm here
their butter is
i can't even describe it it's like
butter there's a name of there's a name
of it too it's like the something that's
like the best
and the pepper and the way that you put
it on the bread and the and the butter
is like perfection it's the best butter
i've had in my life so i actually want
to ask you a business question about
this because i'm sure there's people
being like okay i'm never gonna go to
monaco but
a lot of the people that work for you
probably have that i'm never going to be
able to go to monaco but some of the
like i've met a million of your of your
agents there's 20 000 or whatever i've
done good friends with a bunch of them
right now
their dreams have become a reality
that's what i think is the most amazing
thing about your other company you've
done php is that you've taken
ordinary people and you've made them
extraordinary or made their lives
extraordinary you know i don't want to
name names here but some of these people
would have no chance to go to a place
like paris or monaco on a trip like this
but you always say treat your best
people right so maybe like give it some
insight like there's people out there
being like yeah i wish i could be like
pat go to monaco but like no you could
be the guy that you know maybe got
caught up in the propeller or something
like that
but there's regular people that are have
extraordinary lives with php would you
break that down at least i listen you
say like they would have never had the
experience i would have never had the
experience i'm a regular guy i don't
relate to the
guys that you know come from families
who had the money to go to schools and
four-year degrees eight-year degrees i'm
a guy that would have done 20 years in
the military and i would have gone out
five years ago mm-hmm five years ago it
had been 20 years wow i got a call from
a guy named kogan who told me you should
get out because i think you can do very
well in the market
and i thought about it overnight and i
didn't realist and i got out and life
wasn't easy for a couple years before
business took off it was hard for a long
time before it took off so these guys
were were similar you know you got a
dream and sometimes when you got a dream
and
you you know you're at the inception of
it when you're chasing it
everything says there's no way you can
pull this off everything everything says
you're not good enough what makes you
think you can pull this up what makes
you think you what makes you think
what part of your background's like you
can't even go towards a place in your
life that you succeeded to say well you
were the mvp of your high school
football team i never played organized
sports while you were the valedictorian
i had a 1.8 gpa well you were the chess
never played chess while you were
there's nothing that you can go to to
say
that i ever won in anything in my life
from first grade to no joke to senior
year
maybe i got five a's
i'm talking from first grade that's
saying something okay dylan already got
five days in the second grade
i don't know if i've had that many a's
from first grade i hope my kids are not
listening guys if you're listening i'm
not telling the truth that my gpa was
4.5 basically saying it's not the size
of the dog in the fight it says the
fight in the dark there is no question
about it so our guys like zapala's
fighters
fighters yeah palayo
vargas these guys are fighters you know
the riggies of the world we got some
real can i ask you a question about
those guys because i was going to name
them rodolfo ricky and uh guyton because
you've told stories
those guys who are making millions now
they're doing great how like
this is for the business people out
there
you've told stories about jose crying
about uh rodolfo having to move to texas
like didn't speak english came from
somewhere in central america
from the time they started and believed
in you to the time they actually made
money real money i mean like oh okay how
many years was that
well the original guys it took five
years right the original guys but for
supalla's they within a year they made
two 200 within two years they made 660.
but he's someone that experienced third
year they made a million plus with us so
but that's them but
even ricky and erica i mean but i think
by their fourth year they were making
750 and they had never did they didn't
have he was a you know club promoter and
other things that ricky was doing and
you know erica was picking strawberries
and baking soda ricky was a club
promoter he was promoting some other
stuff you know but that's a that's the
safe word
but the reason i asked that question is
because
look we see what's happening in the
stock market today we see
people have gotten so used to getting
rich quick over the last few years
and for me
you're talking speaking of a club
promoter i was a broke the brokest dude
of all my friends living on friends
couches until i actually had to suck it
up you know raise myself from the boot
traps and eat [ __ ] for a few years to
actually make money and what i think is
so appealing about those guys you know
without going through the whole naming
names is for five years they ate [ __ ]
and now they're hanging out in monaco
that's the the story of winning is that
everyone these days young kids just
think oh buy a dogecoin i'm a
millionaire now that's how it works no
[ __ ] it doesn't work that way
yeah it takes time you have to actually
work your ass by the way i i want to
read you guys something i want to read
you guys something i want to read you
guys something so
it's so funny you're saying this
so this guy on linkedin is sending me
messages okay i'm going to show you to
read this message this guy on linkedin
send me messages
very nice guy and he says hey pat i am
i'll read you if you want to look at it
with me you'll come right next to me so
i can read it together
uh uh uh when is this what's your date
can you say the june 16th okay june 16th
ten days uh uh great to see your back to
business again with valuetainment
channel by the way this message is for
everyone who is getting started you're
small you're tiny or worried look what
he says here great to see you back with
valuetainment again uh we would really
like to help support your message i
absolutely love your videos my team has
created a few assets for you is it okay
to send them to you didn't get a chance
to get back he says these are tick-tock
videos i said sure email it to me then
he sends it to you so i look a couple of
these videos the way he did it good i
posted on tick tock got a couple hundred
thousand views i said great
so i'm like okay but have i ever like is
this the first time him and i messaged
so i'm like oh shoot what's this message
above that so i'm looking at two
thousand dollars an hour what is this
all about then when i go all the way to
the top you ready what can you tell them
2015
listen to what i say here listen to what
i say here gideon i met you last year at
social media world conference in a class
where you taught specifically on how to
grow your youtube channel i recently
found out about v-roll and wanted to
reach out to you regarding growing my
youtube channel i'm looking to have
someone consult us on how to grow the
channel to the next level you can find
me on youtube under the username
patrickbetdavid we have roughly 2700
subscribers
wow
that is crazy
look at the innocence
wow i said that roughly 2700 goal is to
take you to 50 000 by the end of the
year i'd love to jump on a call with you
and then he says so here's the point
though here's the point this is what i
was looking for baby
the point is the point is like
when we didn't have bookers i sat my
guys and i said guys why do you think
it's tough to interview a mark cuban i
said i'm going to be the booker and i'm
going to show you we're going to
interview mark cuban so i reached out to
mark cuban and we got an interview with
mark cuban six months later and it was
an exchange what are you looking for i
said hey do you want to i can sell you
10 000 copies of your book he says you
think i need 10 000 copies at 65
no he says but what i do have is an app
i wouldn't mind driving
when we were small
you do everything
you're like you're you're recruiting
you're promoting you're selling you're
driving you're doing this you have to
wear so many hats when you're small
building your business up that you can't
be saying like yesterday we had a couple
people that were consulting they can't
they came up here two partners they're
about to finish the business together
the business doing five six million
dollars a year they're like we're done
okay and it's an ugly meeting okay
and it's a uh it's a software business
that they have their best friends so
they decide to go into business together
and i said okay do you want to be in
business with them i don't know do you
want to be in business with them i don't
know what do you like about your partner
tell me what you like about your partner
you have three things what do you not
like about your part and give three
things what do you not like about a
given thing what do you like about this
party give three things okay so here's
what's gonna happen
if you don't change this he's gonna
leave if you keep going like that you're
not gonna get the best out of them so
what do you guys wanna do what is the
vision so finally we wrote down
that a company that sold 420 million
dollars for them i said is this a nice
exit for you because the other guy runs
eight businesses i'd love to do that do
you believe you guys can do this yes how
long do you think it'll take to get to
this place five years what if it gets to
half the price 60 million you guys so
you get 30 million you get 30 million
you have very happy with that so why
don't we solve for this so what should
we do i said here's what you should be
doing i gave this advice to another guy
yesterday in real estate i was
consulting this is what i said i would
do
i said number one
who are the killers of your industry 20
years ago who are no longer competing
because whoever you talk to that's
competing they're not going to give you
a hundred percent of the best advice but
if you talk to people who were in your
industry 20 years ago i want you to make
a list of anybody who exited did very
well for themselves find them guess what
they do they make a list they found a
guy that exited for 45 million dollars i
said i guarantee you if you call him
he's in his 70s all he wants to do at
that point of his life is to make sure
his time was worth
living and he wants to give value back
to the next generation that's his legacy
him helping you is a big deal to him he
says pat we called the founder of this
company that sold this company 12 years
ago he was on the phone with us for an
hour he wants to have dinner with me my
wife and him and his wife to tell us
everything we ought to do to take the
company to the next one the guy wants
nothing from us right
this these are the things that you gotta
do behind closed doors nobody knows how
business works when you first do youtube
you don't come with a background of
youtube in when you first do real estate
you don't come with a background of real
estate when you first do insurance you
don't come with a background of
insurance but the hustle of you being
able to figure it out on how to pull it
off and learn and get better that's who
ends up winning by the way in every
single industry across the board it
doesn't matter what it is in every
single industry across the board but
yeah when i saw that message on there
and that was in 2700 crazy look can i
can i give a shout out to our friends
here jedediah and vinnie because there's
a lesson there because they just started
their new channels right yeah they took
a risk they right they took a risk
literally less than a month ago and said
screw it i'm leaving my corporate gig
i'm leaving my typically
yeah and i'm going to start something
new yeah right and you've just crossed 5
000 subscribers i want to say i don't
want to sell you short you're about to
hit a thousand you just launched it but
what pat's saying is in 2015 yeah
valuetainment the offices that we're
sitting here with five million
subscribers one and a half years later
2700 and we're trying to get it to 50k
that's the lesson there whether you're a
youtuber or a business person yeah it
might take five years it might take
seven years but look at us now right
that's pretty much how every industry
that's really worth it works i mean
television is the same way i talked to
the first time i came here to talk to
you guys i talked about how i did all
that free tv
it's not easy there's a lot of people in
those moments that say i can't do this
because you think of it and you're like
i remember sitting at that time and
thinking you know what my teacher's
salary is not great i have a small
private tutoring company but it's stable
it's reliable it's coming in it's not
all this stress and i had to make a
decision like do i drop this all which
is reliable stable and go for the gold
what do i do here and i had that little
like devil angel moment and i just went
for it but it's very hard in those
moments even now starting the channel i
got 5 800 subscribers i think we're
eight episodes deep i'm already like all
right man we gotta get you know it's
hard to kind of yeah it's hard to check
yourself and be like this is a process
and do your best work hard but
understand like there are steps that
you're gonna have to go through it's not
gonna be big bang boom that is that's
really challenging for for me in
particular very very challenging you
know what i what i told george when we
one of the nights were sitting there
uh uh actually yes two days ago we had
this conversation on tuesday
i said every time you level up okay so
let's just say you've never made six
figures before you make six figures like
oh my god i'm making six it's kind of
crazy
you ain't gonna get to a million unless
you're you're two tests away from
getting two million
so you're like oh hundred thousand
you're gonna get tested two times before
you get to a million dollar income and
you get to a million dollars like oh i'm
making a million dollar income you're
going to get tested two more times
before you get to a two and a half
million now what ah
you're gonna get tested again and test
it again and every time in life you will
get tested because i don't think the
next level is handed to you without you
being able to show that you can overcome
those tests this happens with content
creation because content creation is to
constantly stay edgy you may have had
one video that goes viral and all of a
sudden you're following is because of
that and then you've never had any other
videos that get a million views well
you're a one you know hit wonder you're
like macarena you're a one-hit wonder
that's what it is right you're but
you're not somebody that's like can do
it but then if you get hits after hits
after hits and you're recreating so we
kept recreating we kept recreating we
kept recreating if you don't recreate
yourself the audience is eventually
going to find somebody that's creative
today because you used to be creative
five years ago but just because you were
created five years ago doesn't mean you
are creative today times are changing
very quickly and we have to keep
adjusting and adapting the market favors
people keep recreating themselves and
people's attention spans are
right here now it's 20 30 seconds less
than a minute whatever whatever so it's
uh it's challenging but it's safe make
sure you're madonna what you just said
made me think of madonna madonna
ray charles recreated herself she's a
creative genius so many times throughout
her career the madonna of the 1980s is
not the madonna of the 1990s is not that
she was always bringing something new
you could love her you could hate her
she was controversial it's all hell yeah
for sure but there was always something
new and spicy and oh do i do i like that
i don't know
really interesting i think all the those
people that you look at
who who are famous who are out there who
are doing something cool there's always
that creative component that kind of
like shocks you every now and then
you're like is that them what are they
doing you know there's that that element
wasn't she crazy about warren
betty and then
together and it's like oh my god it's my
dream and you know one time if yeah i
don't know if you've seen the clip when
she sees antonio
and his wife his wife is there yeah
she's like oh my god you have no idea
like my biggest fantasy you're like this
you're like she's such an interesting
character yeah well do you see what
she's up to very differently she's kind
of losing and she actually she actually
said in an interview when she goes i
admit it she's like i wasn't the best
singer i wasn't but when you believe in
you and you put in that work and you're
wrong you go for it that's right he's a
[ __ ]
madonna but the hardest thing is
when it's time to retire right exactly
they don't want to go
hardest thing they don't want to be like
listen
you got to kind of step away from this
yeah so i don't know if she's that that
fast
but
how old is she is now by the way 60 60
62. do you know who she's uh she's put
out a apb for
she will not date anybody her age she
will only date a young man who's fit and
in his twenties that's it all right guys
that's her rule all right guys i was i'm
good i'm here
you're not in the 20s anymore
you're too tall
do you have any strong feelings on the
fact that she who is 62 will only date a
young man she's madonna adams
but wait a minute what's your point yeah
i'm in my 40s you can't i'm sh i'm like
when men do that it's yeah obviously
it's no problem but when a woman does it
people are like whoa whoa but the only
woman that can do that
it's a madonna type yeah you can't just
be some regular old 62 year old it's
like yeah yeah i'm good dating guys my
age i'm only gonna date
young hot dudes it's like okay good luck
out there gladys it's not happening
but if you're madonna oh yeah forget
about it maybe you got some pull
but donna's different all right
she built different guys i'm getting
worked up i love out of my jacket
so we got we got we got 90 minutes today
because i we got to wrap up at 10 55. so
let's get into the
podcast uh
which story do we want to get into first
let's talk about new york first okay
wealthy i know it's not number one but
let's get into it wealthy new yorkers
who fled
in 2020 took 21 billion dollars in
income with them that's irs income and
this is coming from the irs let me read
the entire story to you so around 300
000 new york city wealthiest residents
who fled during the early days of
coronavirus pandemic two years ago
collectively earned 21 billion dollars
in total income in 2019 according to new
uh data released by the irs so they
collectively earned 21 billion dollars
in income the sum which uh was gleaned
from the iris tax filings were received
in 2020 and 2020 represents represents
the largest flight of capital
from the big apple ever recorded
according to new york times which first
reported on 21 billion dollars
billion billion dollar sum it is double
the average of those who had left new
york over the previous decade according
to the irs 21 000 new yorkers relocated
to new york to florida in 2020 nearly
double the average annual net loss from
uh before the pandemic large financial
firms
set up for offices in sunshine state
attracting a large number of
professionals from the city according to
the irs manhattan transplants living in
palm beach county earned an average of
728
000 a year now here's a question when i
talk to people from new york and jeddah
died this one's going to you when i talk
to people from new york they tell me
they say the phone let's say pat all
those people that left they are coming
back
they're all coming back no one's going
to stay in florida you have friends
there are people that left new york
coming back to new york not really no
especially if you owned a business and
that business went through a lockdown
and you had to shut it down and you had
to figure out other options and you
picked up your family and you picked up
your business and you went to a state
and now you're sitting in a place like
florida and you're realizing wait a
minute i can make a heck of a lot money
more money here because there's not as
much regulation the tax structure is
different and you've just experienced a
better life there's a lot of those
people there's also a lot of people i
think new york is going to have a really
challenging time because of the
structure that existed for a long time
around the office environment you have
all of these gigantic buildings they're
a fortune the rents are extraordinary in
new york city and now you have all this
remote work a lot of those companies are
not going back to in-office work i know
there's a call for a lot of them there's
a lot of them that are just not going to
go back into that structure there's a
lot of people who work in the tech field
companies like google they're not going
back into that structure you have all of
these
really big really expensive empty
buildings in new york city i don't know
what happens to those spaces i really
don't know
but a lot of the people that i talked to
that left are not going back some people
you know keep a little bit of a
footprint there they have family there
they have friends there but there's
really a growing distaste for
a lot of what new york city represents
now and until they get their crime
that's another thing you have some
people that it wasn't about a business
decision it was about a family decision
the crime was through the roof
they're in a place now where they feel
safe where they feel like their kid can
run around and play where they don't
feel like there's a hefty hand of
government where the police force feels
supported and they're saying
even if i do love new york city and what
it represents in my mind that's not what
it looks like today so new york city
would have to take a big step toward
reversing a lot of this damage um and i
don't know remember the prices have to
be worth it right it has to be worth it
you have to say well i'm going to be in
the cultural mecca of the world i'm
going to be in new york city that's not
a good sell if you can't walk through
times square without taking your life in
your hands it's very dangerous right now
still so i think a lot of these issues
it's not if it were just one issue it's
not it's like lockdowns it's mandates
it's uh is there gonna be a second wave
of this and i'm gonna go through this
again it's how dare you do that to my
business it's this heavy hand of
government it's crime it's it's
multi-faceted the reasons why people
left cities like new york california
chicago so it's going to take a lot to
get those people to go back and some of
them just won't i won't i'll never go
back i mind you that you'll never go
back i will never go back to living in
new york and that's home to you that's
home i love my city i love it i grew up
there i like became who i am there and i
have a special bond with it i don't know
if i'll be in florida forever but new
york city it's not
it's not what it once was you would have
to show me that new york city can be
amazing again and i'm not convinced that
new yorkers are going to vote for that
kind of leadership interesting and so
and no being from yonkers new york shout
out to my mom and my aunt that are
watching but uh yeah cause i could you
see it because it's a liberal state
right you think people would bounce and
then they'd be like you know what it's
over we're gonna come back but like you
said the crime is is nuts even my aunt
they don't walk outside at night there's
no chilling in in new york anymore it's
dangerous as [ __ ] and and the fact that
um
what was i saying uh
uh i lost my dream of thought the fact
that the the fact that if you're a new
yorker and you're you love new york and
you bounce and now you're getting used
to this and now you want to come back
it's like come on what i mean also you
have to keep in mind you bring up a good
point about new york as a state the
state's not like that you go upstate new
york it's a different world this is a
new york city new york city is sinking
that state granted the governor is a
disaster she's an absolute monster when
it comes to any issue of freedom or you
know it's preposterous but regardless
that city is is sinking the whole state
so you have people living great lives in
upstate new york and they're like oh
they dread you know when those policies
trickle out from new york and i'm pretty
sure it doesn't help when like the
amazon was going to open in new york
didn't they right what they're trying to
open in amazon and then aoc and all them
were like nah we don't want you here
don't yeah it's not all business friends
don't bring your business here yeah yeah
take your business out here okay yeah
all right i'll fight you by the way what
you said about um new york city is more
liberal and blue and the rest of the
state that's literally for every state
you cannot point to one major city in
the country not one yeah that voted red
just so you know yeah la new york
chicago i'm just i'm just letting you
know every major city votes blue and all
rural votes red and they're all sinking
yeah so there you go
exactly but anyway they are the major
cities in the country but here's my
point
i've
you guys are from new york you're from
l.a well v iran
born and raised in miami i've i've only
lived here my entire life other than my
beautiful stint in addison texas that i
did for seven eight months you speak so
so lovingly about it adam you love texas
i burned out of my apartment never
looked back but i've been seeing new
yorkers
um i've said this before in the podcast
i've been seeing them play hopscotch
with south florida for 20 years now they
come down they have a great time on new
year's they live it up you know when i
was a club promoter back in the day
we're like the new yorkers are coming
we're charging triple the price you know
and then boom they'd pay it you'd make
some money peace out and i would always
wonder
when are these stupid suckers gonna
realize what we have going on here year
round is better rather than just two
weeks for vacation yeah and it took a
freaking worldwide pandemic for them to
be like i'm done with this yeah and
obviously we're seeing what's happening
here now there's people in south florida
and some of our are holding mayor
francis suarez accountable who i voted
for i i really appreciate the guy
they're basically saying
you're bringing all these amazing people
here you're bringing crypto here look at
you know ken griffin citadel capital
they're all coming here what about us
yeah wait i went to paying 2 000 bucks a
month in rent now i got to pay 2 900. i
can't afford it so there's the good and
the bad of all these new yorkers
bringing 21 billion dollars worth of
wealth down to south florida or florida
in general yeah and by the way what you
just said is going to happen you're
going to see some of the people who live
in miami
that can't handle that kind of lifestyle
they're going to live 30 minutes out
they're going to live 30 minutes out and
that happens in every city when they're
like when uh nikki fried was here and
she was talking about what about the
people that can't afford it in la it
happens as well people move to palmdale
california lancaster remember palmdale
lancaster was
everybody moved to palmdale lancaster
all of a sudden quartz hill was like
deep place and condo to live so that's
going to happen as well the test i want
i want to challenge all of you guys this
week to do something
everybody knows somebody in new york
this week
i want you to ask your friends in new
york and see their reaction okay ask
them hey what do you think about this 21
billion dollars of income lost and
you know the story that just came out
saying
300 000 people that left new york the
wealthiest and they're staying in
florida are you seeing people coming
back to new york do you have any stories
like that and just watch their reaction
because i said this i'm gonna do you one
better bro
i said this to somebody who's in the
publishing industry
and she was in the pr business her
reaction
was she was like offended oh really what
do you mean
everybody came back [ __ ] they just
left for that you you don't even know
what you're talking i'm like i'm just
asking a question how are things in new
york everybody comes back this is the
greatest city nobody will ever leave new
york okay that's great to you awesome
now you know it's great you're going to
new york i'm going to new york tomorrow
he's going to new york literally what i
was going to do he's going to new york
tomorrow that would be the weekend and
you're going to
you during i get to meet your mom
my mom and my honor and yonkers this is
amazing also what's really interesting
is because i have friends that are
working in the bar business right now
and they say
it's it's all tourists it's all the
tourists are have come back because they
can get in everywhere now the mandates
have dropped but the people who made it
like the new yorkers
they're not there like i even have a
friend who wanted to open up a hair
salon and she said my you know she was
working at another salon prior to cove
and she's like i want to open it up but
my my new yorkers aren't there anymore
it's like it's a very common type of
feel to it it's a very touristy here for
the moment i got you what you just said
so so it's it's funny you say that
because in la what's happening is a lot
of the guys that that
are the the job creators
those who are doers
they're friends who are doers left yeah
and they're stuck with some people that
are not doers so even though they may
love their state and they're staying
like scott rodriguez just commented
saying i'd love to leave a lot leaving
on a heartbeat but my family's there and
my wife my in-laws families there so
it's hard for him to leave and shout out
to scott you know he uh uh gave a super
chat and wished everybody happy fourth
of july but a lot of people in la who
were like well i gotta stay for my
family
it's very hard when you don't have
people to have dinner with or lunch with
or conversation with or just go shopping
with or just hang out with like what
happened to these friends of mine
they're leaving that's an and you may
love your state as much as you love you
may love your city as much as you love
but generally what you love about your
city
is the culture and culture is the people
people when the people believe the city
is not the city it's just real estate
it's just land yes it's beautiful yes
it's great but it's what it's the people
in that city that make it great now do
you guys think that the that's going to
affect the voting of that state because
i would say no because
at all it actually helped them really it
actually helped them yes of course
because all the same-minded people left
[Music]
that's who left so if they wanted to
strategically
to lock in voting yeah and not have to
worry their strategy is actually what's
working i got you their strategy they
wanted to thank the city and create a
bunch of government dependents
why are you surprised what was the
richest city in the world 80 years ago
what was the reason
detroit detroit was winning the
motorcycle yeah what happened to detroit
hey the politicians got involved yeah
dearborn everything ruined the entire
city everybody left so if it can happen
to detroit we're not either that's how i
ended up in florida my dad's from
detroit his family home moved to miami
in the 70s yeah and then they started
dealing with pablo escobar and we won't
talk about that but that's how my family
got here you guys just made a great
point that's why people that talk you
know the republicans talk [ __ ] about joe
biden but yo joe biden is doing a
fantastic job it's all about perspective
they want that they want you know the
middle class gone be relying on the
[ __ ] government so he's doing i mean
that's fantastic then he's doing it he's
doing exactly what he's supposed to do
that's a good job pain promise
fulfillment yeah good job okay good job
i'm not gonna let you get negative on
this no i'm not negative he didn't he he
said that's what he was going to do he's
doing it yeah hey joel was like have a
little respect for the president hey hey
middle class [ __ ] your fact middle class
go fight yourself and now he's doing a
great job pissed off adam yeah now he
told you is that there
all right let's go to this next one here
uh is it more uh it's now more expensive
to own a home than rent one
at any time uh since 2000 so this is a
story on page two market watch
the housing market may be slowing down
but only go home is still a costly
proposition two
charts reveal exactly how expensive it
is if you want to put that up there
tyler so people can see it just over a
year ago the monthly cost of owning and
renting were practically identical
according to a blog post from john burns
real estate uh consulting now owning a
home costs 839 dollars more per month
than renting the differential is almost
200 higher than any time
since the turn of century 20 years ago
22 years ago daniel uh win senior
research manager at john burris road
across residential properties renting a
home would set back set one back roughly
1962
across according to data from redfin uh
as of april 2022 two months ago but if a
homeowner had put down seven percent
down payment for home they'd be stuck
with a mortgage that would set them
21.14 a month 152 more with demand now
shifting toward renting home builders
who were once reluctant to sell rental
home investors are now soliciting offers
from investors
strong demand from investors will
provide additional support to today's
home prices when added so when you look
at that chart right there take a look at
that look how it's been it's been all
about buying
buying buying and now it's renting and
the last time it peaked not even at that
level what year is that by the way is
that 0506 06 yeah exactly what's the red
versus the blue red is it's better to uh
blue is rent
yeah no blue's rent and red is owned
okay so it was good to own in after the
financial crisis oh wait prices went
down but other than that it's always
been cheaper to rent april in the last
20 years is whatever but by the way
here's here's what you have to know
though what if you look at this this is
what you have to know
look how sick that drop is on when it is
good to to to buy look what your debt is
look at the exact money right right
exactly okay
go to the exact month boom no no the
month it's not it's not financial crisis
april 09.
april 09. so april 09 is how much after
financial crisis november 07 is when
countrywide new century wamu everybody
starts saying we're not doing pick a
payment loan yeah the no income no
assets
nina they stopped doing in november of
07. so if you look at november of 07
there the drop is coming so it took
november of 07 until april of 09
which means
november of 07 april 9 is how long
that's 18 months give or take
so this means 18 months from
april
what is 18 months from april 18 months
from april is go eight months
then add another 10 months
april is eight months uh 10 months
october of next year
is going to be perfect time to buy and
it's gonna go like that for about three
years four years do you see that so from
october of oh uh 2023
till about october of 2026
2027 that's when it's gonna be the best
time to be buying so if you're sitting
there by the way if you're a realtor
right now trying to sell this what i'm
saying to you right now you may want to
not have them listen to this like don't
share this message don't listen to that
but if you're the person that is selling
and if you're thinking about selling and
again we talked about on the last
podcast don't be greedy selling right
now do not if you're trying to sell sell
but if you're just trying to like you're
thinking maybe i want to sell i don't
want to sell hang on to your house but
if you want to buy
you may want to wait 18 more months
isn't it crazy like and we talked about
this all the time like everybody's
talking about the markets come in the
markets and crash have you ever thought
that you'd actually say the words like
oh my god like people ask me
you're gonna live here forever you're
gonna buy a house i'm just like just
waiting for that market to crash
i never thought i'd say some [ __ ] like
that like the only person that knew when
the crash happened was michael bury
right he was the only one spinning now
everybody's like come on man let's let's
have everything crashed so i could buy a
[ __ ] i'm gonna jump in and what two
things number one i'm shocked you see
how like all the way to the right
basically when covet hit yeah april of
20 that's where the a little red starts
showing up yeah you would think it'd be
more than that with the fury of buying
that's been going on
it's
clearly it if i'm looking at this the
only time it was actually good to buy
was after the financial crisis that's
what i'm looking at of course i see blue
blue blue blue blue wave like it's a
liberal city out over here and then it's
a good divide during the crisis here's
my point i say this all the time
all the time okay
owning a house and buying a house and
taking out a mortgage and taking on debt
ain't all that it's cracked up to be the
realtor association of the world
uh has done a great job of saying
renting is throwing away money renting a
stronghold what they want and my mom by
the way exactly because that's what the
american dream was 50 years ago buy a
house two-car garage picket fence 2.2
kids that's what the american dream is
the american dream today is economic
freedom pick and choose wherever the
hell you want to go keep it moving and
stay flexible and keep your
overhead low so what people forget is
that all right you know that if you're
going to buy a place
first thing you're going to look at is
the mortgage payment right so typically
in the last six months it's gone from
three percent to six percent that's
double i'm not a mathematician but i'm
pretty sure three to six
but the three things that people forget
about when they go to buy a house and
for those of us that have bought a house
they get it now those of us that have
not is what i call the big three
expenses that's your taxes your
maintenance and your insurance those are
three things you do not have to pay for
if you're renting exactly so
everyone's like well it's cheaper to to
buy or it's the same price it's like
yeah go ahead and figure out what your
maintenance is going to be what your
taxes are going to be and what your
insurance is going to cost oh you just
moved to florida you ever heard of a
[ __ ] hurricane buddy you're going to
need some hurricane insurance so
there's a difference between an
investment and a lifestyle choice yeah
buying a house isn't exactly the best
investment it might be the best
lifestyle choice but there is a
difference you can look at the math
if you put your money in the s p 500
index fund over 10 years versus buying a
house the s p is gonna double what
you're gonna get for your house got you
yeah there's also headaches and small
costs that like you think of it you're
talking about big costs and but i you
know i've never owned a home i lived in
new york city so i always rented it just
didn't make sense for me and there's
there's little things that come up the
dishwasher breaks the washer dryer
somebody comes in you rent somebody
comes in rolls in and replaces that
that's not your headache that's not your
time that's not your money so if you add
up all that stuff it winds up being a
much bigger picture of what the costs
and expenses are to actually own a home
i will say that the owning versus
renting for me was always like mind [ __ ]
because i always grew up feeling like if
you own something it's yours you have it
at the end you can touch it i don't like
stop touching it because i can touch it
and if they if they take everything else
away from you
you have your home but you know shout
out to the realtors and the realtors and
my mom hi
by the way absolutely but yeah you know
that's a feeling that's a feeling that
some of us had growing up and it's the
same for a car i know my parents were
always like own your car because if you
lease it never owned a car always you
know
but that that's a that's just a mental
game sometimes you have to play mental
and a car is only worth 40 grand we're
talking about a place that's worth a
million dollars yeah you know who i got
to give a shout out to certain cities
pbd because anytime i have this argument
i'm like oh oh pull up that remember
that article you wrote for the denver
post back in whatever year 2004
pat had i don't know half a million
bucks a million bucks in the bank you
just started to do really well and you
had to make an economic decision do i
buy a place or take all my money and
invest it in the business what'd you do
no no i put in the business but you but
my my idea was nothing gives me higher
rate of return than putting money into
the business bingo nothing does i mean
that's just until today anything
if i have access to capital i'm putting
that into the business i'm not putting
that into a house now
it's also different when you
have eight people living in your house
it's also different when you're
positioning on where your kids are going
to school it's also different where
you want to paint the house in a certain
way you don't need to get somebody's
permission when you have all of that
stuff so life would it would be slightly
different for you if you had a wife and
a kid but this is exactly what i'm
saying but it's lifestyle no question
about you you have no kids you have your
father you're right you've got melva
like you're right like you have to buy
absolutely but if you were just you and
jen and one kid you would maybe even
still consider listen if i'm running a
business today if i'm a business owner
today and i have a choice between
putting half a million dollars into a
house and putting half a million dollars
into my business the business is going
to give you 10 times if you're a good
operator 10 times more return on the
money than real estate is yep so so if
you're in the inception phase of
building a business and you want to use
your resources to grow your business
you're wasting your money putting into
it but a realtor will never tell you
i'll never tell you that but by the way
here's can you go back to that chart
and uh jorge eric can we increase the
mic by like five or ten percent because
i can't hear myself so if you if you go
back to this chart so you know the
concept of a slingshot what's the
concept of a slingshot you pull it back
and then boom it goes
but the further you pull it back what
happens
the further it goes right yeah guys look
how how much higher that is
than it was at the
in in 07. i love what you're making
do you know what that means
that means the red that you see there
that red is going to be much lower
listen i'm not
i'm all i'm saying is if and look how
quickly the spike is
in the last two do you see the spike
like how fast it went up boom it didn't
go up that fast if you look at the uh
the one on the left the spike on the
right only took
look at that that's fast
on the left oh my gosh scary right there
because this if if this if we go purely
on the slingshot
metaphor
real estate in about
three five years man it may be like a
two and maybe a stack cash again you're
ready to buy your drawers home in the
next six years don't rush i don't know
mark sitting because that guy didn't
take my yeah in some markets it's about
to be a massive dip
if this continues the way it is by the
way can we follow this the next time
this gets updated to see what the next
one is because if it goes even higher
uh
let's update this chart quarterly and
let's see what's going on revisit this
chart can you put this save this to like
favorites or something i will never
complain about my twenty one hundred
dollar rent for a really small apartment
never again
because everybody's gonna know you when
you move here you're right i'm looking
to buy money
i'm gonna give credit where credit is
due at i've just walked in i just met
him two minutes he goes hey you're new
come here don't buy a [ __ ] house oh
yeah hi i'm vinnie yeah exactly he's
like don't buy a phone and then i
slapped you in the face because you said
i think i saw you know i told you the
exact same thing i said give it a year
jedediah yeah yeah look at this did this
not prove my point yeah yeah he goes
save your money but then he made me take
him to sushi
300 wow that's a commission right it's a
commission right there yeah yeah i don't
know i i don't know i don't know that
people cut this message because this is
real wow if if you cut this message this
is real what's going on anyways and
michael berry keeps saying it and
michael berry still doesn't want to do
an interview with anybody he will he
turns on every single interview that he
gets asked to do
uh but that is one guy you watch closely
two movies you gotta watch okay two
movies go watch two movies go watch
margin call go watch big short these are
two movies you gotta watch this weekend
listen folks listen add it to your list
watch margin call and watch big short
you'll realize what's going on it'll
give you a hint for someone because that
maybe don't like to read you'd much
rather get your content watch it watch
those two movies this weekend the
difference is
2007 2008 it was all mortgage-backed
securities and bad bets and you know and
bear stearns and these types of folks
now it's what the
massive
money printing yeah quantitative easing
there's
a different
method to the madness but
i don't know what any of that means but
guess what it sounds scary as [ __ ] just
rent is what that means
yeah but people that actually know what
they're doing with their money and you
don't have to get caught up in
quantitative easing and mortgage rates
and mortgage-backed securities rent make
money
save your money be smart with your
investments the recipe is simple did you
get that story i sent you yesterday
tyler with interest rates uh being
projected to go up another three
quarters of a point to a point in july
the the and and the lady that said it
and powell is like oh we're working very
hard to not have the recession i sent
you the story yesterday you should have
it somewhere here
uh uh
uh but yeah so anyway so even with this
going on
if the rates go another three quarters
of a point next month to a point that's
going to go spike even higher yep every
time they raise rates that's just going
to go higher and higher and higher
and and i haven't powell seems very
confident
that they're going to be able to prevent
america from going into recession folks
if the definition of recession is two
quarters in a row the gdp
slows down
today's what date i believe today's what
date today is the 30th 30th of june
tomorrow's officially day one of
recession oh [ __ ]
if it's two quarters in a row tomorrow
is officially day one of recession and
watch no one talk about it wow
watch no one talk about it until first
quarter of 2023 loretta mester says fed
is on track for three quarters of a
point to
increase in july rate hike go a little
higher go a little higher to see what
this article says can zoom in a little
bit
uh federal reserve bank of cleveland
president lauren says the u.s central
bank is on track for another big
interest rate hike next month based on
current economic conditions if the rate
setting federal open market committee
meeting was being held today miss messer
said wednesday on cnbc that she would
advocate for three she would advocate
for three-point coin uh hike rate hike
uh because i haven't seen the kind of
numbers on the inflation side that i
need to see in order to know
in order to you know that we can go back
to
50 basin basis point increase wow mrs
messer said high readings of inflation
mean the fed needs to raise rates
quickly to restrain
those forces so far this year the fed
has increased its short-term rates from
near zero uh to 1.5 to 1.75 and
officials signaled a number of further
increases are likely
this year as inflation has it afforded
your eye oh my goodness okay all right
brace for impact folks
remember when the race
transitory say that again remember when
they told you this was all training yeah
this was transitory well janet yellen
you know she's uh
she's a gem
uh powell says no guarantee fed can
avoid hard landing obviously no
guarantee fed can avoid
hard landing how do you process that
statement the recession is coming it's
saying he's he's covering his ass of
course he is yeah this is yeah we can't
guarantee it's gonna be a soft landing
of course it's not it's it's gotten
harder the pathways have gotten narrower
powell said
uh at a european central bank event on
wednesday nonetheless that is our aim
and there are pathways to achieve that
go lower what is your pathway powell
power zones
mentioned or said is significantly more
challenging
but russia invasion of ukraine fuel oil
prices have jumped 36 of nation
sanctions
okay i i listen this is uh
a real dilemma yeah this is a real
dilemma and this is a this is a real
dilemma look
here's all you have to be thinking about
this is what you have to be thinking
about
if you're a short-term thinker you're in
trouble
if you're a long-term thinker
you're doing fine
a guy who runs a mortgage company in l.a
i was talking to him yesterday i said
you know you know what i you know what
event would sell out right now
maybe can you tell this to mario maybe
we even put it together ourselves we
just booked five we're about to announce
the five speakers at the vault it's
freaking sick uh the the two show the
two entertainment alone that we're gonna
be having many people will just come for
the show but you'll be surprised who
we're inviting today it's freaking
jam-packed more than the two events
vault we put together combined we'll be
announcing that can we go can we go
maybe we'll announce the next two series
but i'm gonna say this to you here
if i was
maybe just make a note we'll do this
event just make a note we'll do this
event and we're gonna charge pretty much
nothing the tickets for this event the
tickets for this
500 tickets like cheap tickets will do
here's what i'm gonna do
i would put a mortgage event right now
a two-day mortgage event okay
and at this mortgage real estate event
i'm bringing all the godfathers fathers
of real estate from 20 years and by the
way if somebody else wants to do this go
do it i really don't care i'm not going
to be upset if somebody else takes this
and does it before i do so i don't have
to do it somebody needs to do this event
have two thousand
have an event with all the godfathers of
real estate that were around that
they're out in 0807 the ones that were
in in the 90s when real estate took a
crash and have a lineup of all of them
with a panel for two days and have
realtors loan officers only show up you
would sell thousands you'd sell out the
what is this arena here miami arena with
ftx you would sell i was about this
american you would sell at the ftx arena
of realtors and loan officers to sit
down and say
i would have bernanke there i would have
the guys that messed with uh uh
i would have any one of these guys that
were involved with raids fed all of that
in a room saying guys how ugly is this
going to be tell us so we can prepare
short term is going to be ugly but i
think the guys that are in it for a long
time i think they're going to be fine
sell your exotics sell your patek
philippe watch sell all of that mess uh
wives if you're listening i told this to
wife yesterday
take a break from chanel for three years
take a break from louis vuitton for
three years take a break from hermes for
three years go back to coach no more
neiman marcus no more nordstroms go to
macy's go to walmart dial 17.
tarjay has got a lot of good selection
for you if you want to go there
amazon's got great selection forget
about the name brand for the next three
years rather than driving a bentley go
drive that chrysler that looks like a
bentley yeah rather than driving a
ferrari go get a corvette it looks just
like a ferrari
rather than driving any of the you know
the rolls-royce phantom just go get a
nice sedan s-class that's a hundred
grand you don't have to pay 500 000 for
that phantom
just back up a little bit the next two
three years luxuries set them aside you
got a patek philippe watch or rolex go
get yourself a citizen it's still going
to tell you the time maybe get an apple
watch if you want to yeah but it's a
time to take a break i want them to cut
this up into a short clip and put that
out because you're absolutely right this
is exactly what people need to do
because there's been so much easy my i
thought like the hermes the chanels the
louis vuittons of the world we're going
to get crushed during covid yeah people
out of jobs people not traveling there's
no one to impress
they've skyrocketed for a brief period
of time
uh the owner of lvmh what's the the
french guy's name in uh
i don't remember look up the owner of
that ridiculously like
those names he became in the end
bernard i'll know yes i believe yeah
that's
he became the richest man in the world
ahead of bezos and elon musk for a
quarter during covid because all these
people got their stimulus checks yeah
time to go get that louie back yo and i
thought these companies were gonna get
crushed they skyrocketed but their time
is a comment you'd have to call that
event the godfather's real estate that
would just look what i am so tempted to
hold do it eventually ftx and just do it
do it sell tickets for nothing and
invite everybody godfather mario said
he's excited to plan it yes
yeah by the way let me ask you a
question how many of you guys who are in
real estate and mortgage
would want to attend like how much is it
to rent out ftx arena how much would it
be to run out of money oh my god can you
find out
can you text keep to see if you can find
out sure see how much it is to round out
the american era
with insurance and everything if we did
it for one day if you have interest your
real estate mortgages you want me to go
call these guys and bring everybody in
the room
would you what would you spend for a
ticket if we do it for cause i'm gonna
do it for cost whatever the cost is
we'll cover it 500 bucks a thousand
dollars a ticket i think everybody in
the mortgage real estate business needs
to be prepared for this time to come so
find out if we can get the ftx arena and
how much that is maybe we'll do that
event but so this is my question pat
like we're talking about people don't go
buy the maybach buy the s-class for a
hundred grand or don't buy hermes or
chanel or whatever what about the people
that literally have never been in that
realm that were only making 50 60 70 80
000 a year response for you as well now
they're in retirement and as you see
we've lost three trillion dollars of
retirement savings what do they do
fantastic question by the way fantastic
question so let's talk to the baby
boomers you ready let's talk to the
people above 60. you want to start at
that generation first absolutely let's
start there first okay if you're 60 i
hate to say to you you're not 60. you
were 60 60 years ago if you were 60 then
today if you're 60 you're 40 years old
because you're living to 85 years old
stop thinking you're 60 years old you're
45 years old you are naive if you're
what i'll do respect to boobers i got
respect for you because you came before
i did with all due respect if you are
naive if you're a boomer at 60 thinking
about retiring in five years you ought
to change your retirement plan to 12
years at 72
not because oh my gosh that's so unfair
the government is so unfair no because
you're gonna live longer and if you
decide to retire at 65 you'll be broke
at 79 years old miserable being a little
bit of a challenge to your kids you may
even come in between your kids marriage
whoever they're married to because
they're going to be sitting there behind
closed doors in bed saying how much more
money do we have to take care of your
mom how much more money do we have to
pay for your dad you may cause a divorce
amongst your kids and whoever they're
married to so game plan you're 60 you're
going to 72 have the conversation with
your wife have the conversation with
your husband go get a side gig whatever
that side gig maybe do real estate go to
retirement go do insurance guess what
sell whatever people at your age are
interested in because that's your market
go sell meds up go sell med advantage go
sell you know a long-term care go sell
whatever experience you are going
through go sell a 401k and say listen
this was my 401k a 700 700 000 it's at
420. if you're like me this is what i'm
doing do you want to hear about it
figure out a way to generate income for
yourself i talked to a lot of them and
they're in that age 60 plus and a lot of
them are flat out saying i'm not retired
at 65. and they have a million in the
bank
in their retirement and they have 2
million in retirement a million 2
million of retirement today at 60 years
old is nothing crazy because you got a
plan for at least 25 years you have to
plan to 85 don't solve for i'm gonna die
at 72 years old no you're going to solve
for 85 years old and by the way
everybody else
30 year old 40 year old 50 year old
that's going through a mess maybe by the
way the divorce business is going to
blow up next two years yeah i can
imagine it's sad but it's sad but it's
going to blow up the next two years
therapy is going to blow up the next two
years i hate to say it and i hope this
industry doesn't blow up they're going
to because the first thing doctors are
going to prescribe is what trust
anti-depressants are going to blow up
the next two years oh yeah you're gonna
see a lot of weird stories the next two
years we talked about this the other
night that we're here if you're
listening to this and you're scared only
be scared if you're not planning to
increase your value in the marketplace
you have nothing to be scared of if you
are going to be improving and learning
two three four five new skill sets to
improve yourself in the marketplace
because the market is going to pay you
if you improve
the people that are scared today are the
people that are watching way too many
tick tock videos way too many instagram
videos way too many netflix shows way
too many video games let me tell you if
you're watching this get off this
podcast because this podcast is going to
be very scary for you the next 3 6 12
months because i'm not going to stop
talking about this get off your damn
video games and the netflix take a
six-month sabbatical from netflix and
freaking video games and tick-tock take
a break
and go learn a skill set go on udemy go
on pluralsight go on any of these
whatever courses you can take there go
take some master class go take a
work under somebody to learn something
go watch some youtube videos from people
that are teaching you there's great real
estate youtube videos there's great
insurance youtube videos there's one
called seven-figure squad there's so
many of them that you can go learn from
these people out there but if you don't
do that
don't blame the government
don't blame the rich people don't blame
your parents don't blame your family
don't blame anybody if you refuse to
improve you the next two years and by
the way i hate to say to you this
happened to my family and nine and when
i got out of the military in 1999 i got
out of the military my dad had another
heart attack he went to the hospital we
were watching the game where allen
iverson made that shot over uh
tyrone lou wow game ended he says take
me to the hospital i'm having a heart
attack i took him to the hospital he's
having a heart attack i'm saying like oh
great 49k in debt buddy you're killing
it pvd what are you going to do the only
thing you know how to do is shoot a
freaking rifle and you're not even an
expert at it you were advanced
so what am i going to go say uh listen
ibm you guys need somebody with a good
you know
i
i want to say i'm going to be a hummer
mechanic i'm going to go be the best
humber mechanic in california there was
200 dealerships
one was in camarillo here's what the guy
said in the interview no joke he told me
says sir i said i'm the best hummer
mechanic in all of fort campbell
kentucky look at my i'm sick yeah i'm
your best he says sir we sell two
hummers a month
we have one mechanic and it's one too
many that's a perfect we don't need you
i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] what a waste of a
skill set i can shoot and i can fix
summers and i'm broke you still got hope
they're bringing it back there's still
hope but the point is i i sat there and
i said i'm gonna increase my market
value i think that's what everybody can
do that's amazing if you don't do it you
should be scared if you do do it don't
worry about it future looks bright let
me let me tell you something number one
uh you're on fire today i love this so i
don't know i love uh what you're saying
here uh let me talk to the older people
out there aka if you're not listening
your parents and then i'll talk to
people our age i actually had this exact
same conversation with my mom this week
my mom's 70 years old i go mom don't
plan on retiring
anytime soon you're she's a nurse she
runs the front desk at a nursing
facility you're going to be working
until you're 80. get used to it what are
you going to do retire and do freaking
nothing you don't golf you don't play
mahjong there's nothing for you to do
a generation ago
you hit 65.70 that's it time for social
security i'm dead in the next five years
my mom god bless god willing is gonna
make it to a hundred okay so are all our
parents if they take care of themselves
yeah what are you gonna do live on the
government for the next 30 years with
your couple hundred grand in your 401k
it's not going to happen mom keep
working now what to pat said and this is
exactly what i tell young people you
have two choices as to what to do with
your time your time is your greatest
commodity you can either spend your time
or invest your time what pat's talking
about playing video games and being on
netflix congratulations buddy you spend
your time i was the king of spending my
time in my 20s clubbing partying fantasy
football [ __ ] about until i had to
like time to invest my time reading
content creating networking that's when
i saw my life improve so the choice is
yours yeah and just piggybacking for you
so my mom's retired pat my sister uh
veronique she's retiring from the air
force next month after 25 years she's
getting out bro she's not retiring and
kicking her feet up she's going to use
the skill sets from the military she has
to get a [ __ ] job you know what i
mean because her my mother i'm moving to
california my mom's income and my
sister's income are going to just bare
like basically just get them rent
because they're not going to buy you
know what i mean they have to rent right
now in california so that's how you're
right
yeah and also i think it's a it's an
opportunity to kind of like think about
what you really like i have a friend
whose mom retired from
you know traditional jobs she's had for
years she always liked this sounds crazy
she always liked basket weaving she
started a basket weaving business and is
selling this stuff at home
went on etsy started a shop you know so
you it doesn't have to be a lot of
people say oh i worked in an office for
x amount of years i'm burnt out i can't
it doesn't have to be in that box that
way of thinking you can branch out i
have another friend 50 years old became
a personal trainer decided that was
always a passion of his didn't do that
his whole life was in banking hated
banking got out of banking was like i
don't know what to do let me go do
something different so it can it doesn't
have to be like this straight line it
can be kind of all over the place think
of it like a tree branch i've even
thought about getting a personal
training certification i love to
exercise why not why not have that in my
back pocket if i ever want to open a spa
if i ever want to open a gym which is a
dream that i have to open something
wellness oriented me having that
certification that's a plus for me so
i'm thinking about doing that right now
even though i'm doing the podcast it
doesn't have to all be
you know eggs in one basket you can
really think outside the box and now
more than ever i feel like it's a time
for people to do that
let me tell you something that because
obviously you know my core business in
the insurance world and uh life
settlements 60 sorry a hundred thousand
baby boomers turn 65
every single day wow okay for the next
decade
baby boomers up until millennials became
the largest generation 80 million plus
are the largest generations so this is
advice to your parents like i doubt
there's many seven-year-olds listening
right now there's a few
but
the hardest thing you to do at 65 is
realize you probably are going to live
another few decades yeah and it's going
to be it's very hard to do especially if
you're not technologically savvy to
update your skill set
but
you know
it's hard to do but you got to do it and
if my mom's listening my mom dude my mom
is one of the best cooks ever mom gordon
z truck or a kiptech truck just start
selling she's i mean my mom is literally
classic just i don't know what you just
said but i know you said like the person
are you asking your mom
like crack for middle class from
i'm being real my mom is one of the best
cooks and i've eaten a lot of food from
a lot of different people my mom's going
to come visit she already made carrot
cake that one time that i almost got
arrested at the airport with the flowers
my mom
what's wrong my mom makes a carrot cake
and it's your competition worthy care
i'm not i know people
am i right no jokes sick so i'm she's
i'm coming here i'm moving here we got
the job with pat and my mom makes this
carrot cake and
there's confection sugar that you're
supposed to put once you serve it she
puts it in the middle of the cake jen
without letting me know i show up to
[ __ ] lax my bag goes through and i'm
not joking you know the x-ray people you
can't really see them yeah it's a black
girl and she just sends up and she goes
oh hell no
i'm like what she's like is that you
cops everybody i go what the hell is
going on i'm not stupid i don't bring i
don't have drugs i'm not she goes what
the hell she pulls out this bag it's
confection sugar looks just like cocaine
yeah and my mom writes a no this is
sugar yeah don't this is not cocaine
yeah okay the guy goes just for the
drugs
oh this is the first time we've gotten
the this isn't cocaine this is sugar
trick but like she my mom's cooking is
amazing we might have to open up a
carrot cake shop but that's exactly what
all our moms and dads need to be
reconsidering rather than aging out of
the workforce reinvented why i during
times of crisis small businesses get
started let's remember this small
businesses get started during times of
crisis so awesome okay let's continue
let's continue with the next story next
story is tick tock okay
fcc commissioner urges tick tock to be
removed from apple
google stores over unacceptable national
security risk a fox business story let's
see what this is all about so
uh
papa here we go in a letter dated june
24 brandon carter the commissioner of
federal trade federal commission
communication commission
warren apple ceo
tim cook an alphabet ceo
sundar pa pichai of an alarming new
report that shed fresh light on serious
national security threats posed by tick
tock
tick tock is not what it happened what
it appears to be on the surface it is
not just an app for sharing funny videos
or memes that's the sheep's clothing car
wrote
at its core tick-tock functions as a
sophisticated surveillance tool that
harvests
extensive amounts of personal and
sensitive data
tick tock available to millions of
americans through apple and google
online stores is owned by the
beijing-based company by dance a
organization an organization that car
asserts is
behold to the communist party of china
required by chinese law to comply with
the prc surveillance demands i i would i
would understand this under a trump
administration to come out a story like
yeah but if it comes out under trump and
biden guess what it is it's real yeah i
agree 100 it's real how do you feel
about this yeah i mean i i don't have a
tic tac i i've thought about it i think
it's appealing like as you know a tool i
thought about it for the show but i am
concerned about this you remember when
trump brought this up and everyone was
like oh that can't be he's just trying
to shut down a company he's trying to be
you know he's he's now big daddy
government but the reality is there's a
lot of stories there was a story that
came out in buzzfeed recently about this
that was talking about how there was
data of u.s users that was accessed by
entities in mainland china so it's a
concern are they harvesting data what
are they doing with the data if are they
holding on to it what kind of personal
data are they able to retain what are
they going to do with it i mean you
don't want the chinese government having
access to that data so it's a concern
i'm so you know and it's interesting to
me because this has been a story that's
now gone through two administrations
this doesn't seem like it has a
political bent to me it doesn't seem
like it's a part of a political
narrative so i'm surprised that more
people aren't tuned into it and this is
tick-tock is the home of young people
right young people are plugged in left
and right so do they not care like does
that is this not a concern at all i mean
privacy privacy i understand people feel
like in 2020 2022 you know privacy is
dead but they're talking about your
personal data your personal information
that could be the posses in the
possession of the chinese government so
yes absolutely 100 this is something
that crosses my mind every single time i
consider doing a tick tock i take a
pause i sit back and i don't do it
because i'm worried about where this
data is going who's holding on to it and
then they said something about oh we can
modify this and we can have you know
it be controlled within the united
states well that doesn't matter it
doesn't matter all that data is still
going to be transferred over to china
it's still going to be in their
possession so i get comes down to a
question these are again this doesn't
seem to be politically motivated this is
crossing to administrations are you
comfortable with your personal data
potentially being in the hands of
mainland china and the chinese
government if no you might want to
consider your presence on tick tock if
yes i don't know what to say and i'll
pick you back in a ver and i think this
is what's messed up today you could tell
all these all these kids all these you
know middle-aged people that are on
there
the truth and what's happening they're
addicted they're not they don't give a
[ __ ] you could tell them they're making
a [ __ ] ton of money interrupting a [ __ ]
ton of money yep 100 you could tell them
to their face this is all going to china
that you know
it's oh you god knows what the hell
they're doing with it you know they
would say okay fine whatever i got i
gotta leave i have to go make another
video same thing with that remember that
old face swap app
look
everybody and their mother was doing it
was doing the pandemic that's a
russian-based company that the facial
recognition facial recognition they got
all your goddamn faces
and that that comes back to my point i
was i was actually talking about this to
rob earlier bro china is they're they're
just gangster both they can do whatever
they want they own us they can get away
with everything but still to this day
like we still haven't held them
accountable for colvin isn't that crazy
that's how gangster uh china is what are
they gonna do with it though the data
you think about it like think about an
influencer you know a 20-something
influencer now making half a million
dollars a year off of tick-tock videos
because they do you can make a [ __ ] ton
of money and it's not hard to make money
on tick tock because of the way the
algorithm works if you post a lot you
can make a lot of cash which is why i
was like should i consider that it's
good show promotion but what is the
chinese government that's the other
thing because i think people sit back
and they read a story like this and they
say well what are they going to do with
my stuff i'm just an influencer i'm
promoting products i'm 20 something
years old they're not going to harm me
what what so what that's the question
for me too though well you know
what what are they going to do your
picture your images your personal
information
your voice what what is that data breach
what is the potential where where can
that land that can be scary for your
average 25 year old who sees themselves
as disconnected from this story i don't
know yeah well they say you know uh
regarding social media if you're not
paying anything for it and you're not
buying a product you are the product 100
okay so with tick tock i believe this is
china's sort of tick tock trojan horse
into america and trump has been talking
about taking away tick tocks for two
years now right yeah but
for young people two things
they've grown up with scroll scroll
scroll except they don't they're not
reading the disclaimer what's happening
with the data so what they're doing
three things to take away from young
people they're taking away their minds
right needlessly just scrolling seeing
stuff that's not helping their lives
number two they're taking their time and
like you said number three they're
taking their data what they're gonna do
with their data whatever the hell they
wanna do who knows with the data why do
you think tesla
is
almost at a trillion dollar market cap
or when it was it's not because they're
selling the most cars ever it's because
they're collecting data they're
collecting data tesla i think elon musk
is famous he said we're not a car
company we're a data company yeah so i
remember that so let me say a couple
things here so i i i eventually ended up
on tick tock okay and if you follow my
tick tock content
it's what tick tock doesn't want for it
to be on okay so that's my approach with
tick-tock
and the audience is young so if i'm in
the job of persuading you to consider
other options and philosophies in life
i want to talk to people that are
disagreeing with me i don't want to talk
to people that agree with my talk to
people that agree with me who am i
converting nobody i want to challenge
your way of thinking that if you
disagree with me i've been putting
content on tick tock for about a year
now okay
and a few of them go viral one got five
million views few them like 10 of them
got a million views and they they spread
by the way much faster than instagram
it's not even the same
two videos
one of them got me taken off of tick
tock for a day that i send an email to
them and support and they apologize the
video that got taken down is when we
talked about nancy pelosi's husband
uh uh making the stock the people that
were saying if you want to be able to
predict the market [ __ ] invest in
whatever nancy pelosi has been investing
i got i got taken off of tick tock for
that surprise i sent an email to them
and a tick tock support on tick tock got
back and said i'm sorry it's a mistake
of ours you know what's the other one
that's been taken that that's not been
taken down that they
took down the video but they didn't uh
suspend the account it was when we
talked about aoc's biggest nightmare is
who
aoc's biggest nightmare is who do you
see remember when we say here look at
this
community guidelines
violation right this video what's the
thumbnail just read the thumbnail
aoc's worst night afc is worse now do
you remember who we said aoc's worst
nightmare was who did she go with on
twitter
oh when she was going with elon elon
musk that video is to say aoc worst
number because and when when elon said
hey i'm shy don't do this remember that
whole thing you have a crush on me they
have not this video was uploaded may
27th this video has not been taken uh
back and i disputed it and they said
we've had your dispute we're still
considering it it's been over a month so
it's stuff like this that tick tock does
which tells you politically which way
they're leaning why did you not take
those videos what's the big deal i
didn't say we didn't talk about vaccine
it was not mask it wasn't covet related
it was a nothing about that aoc and
pelosi both of those reasons the videos
got so now brandon card this guy brandon
carr who is brandon carr he's so here's
who brandon carter check this out the
guy got nominated
he was he ended up being chosen to be
the federal communications uh uh
commissions
in 2017 guess who assigned him that job
a guy named trump donald trump
he he was he was confirmed august of
2017. do you know what's unique about
this when you get this job guess how
long your job is how long is your term
five years oh wow guess when it's five
years is coming up next month
so he may be getting fired i would not
be surprised if this guy gets fired
within six weeks if he gets fired within
six weeks this is his last chance to
bring attention to tick tock being a
concern and we're going to see if
they're going to do anything about it
if this guy does get fired just assume
it's to protect tick-tock if the current
administration biden
chooses to investigate this and go a
little bit deeper that means it is a
topic that they're both on the same page
with and by the way before speculating
let's see if brandon gets fired six
weeks from now if he gets fired six
weeks from now we can speculate as of
right now all i'm telling you is the
guy's job expires in the end of july
okay so let's follow the story to see
what happens to this brandon car guy and
there's a and there's a reason that his
term i'm assuming is five years it's
because you're not gonna get fired when
the administration comes in you're gonna
at least have a year to kind of
transition navigate the waters and
transition but are you not concerned
because i remember you were debating
we've talked about the tick tock you
weren't on tick tock over a year ago i
don't know china trump but you must have
said all right
there's the pros and the cons kind of
like the the angel and the devil you
must say all right the pros i'm gonna
you know put out content i'm going to
convert you know the the convertible
speak to people different but you must
have some data concerns no i of course i
have some data concerns but my concern
is more philosophy concern so you know
people say why would you bring so many
communists that you're interviewing do
you not realize they're indoctrinating
young people who watch your content
no
i want to talk to those guys so there
are arguments you get to choose and say
well that definitely didn't make sense
like remember the guy that said i'm
going to give 70 000 salary to all my
employees you guys remember that one
story yeah what was the price
right if you've never seen this
interview go watch it i told them i said
i can't believe you accepted the
interview with me
uh because uh but i'm impressed that you
did so i said so how did you structure
your company he says i don't believe i
see he says i also only make 70 000 a
year so really yeah everybody in my
company only takes 70 000 a year i said
wow it's very interesting
i applaud you i said what's your company
do we do around 40 million dollars in
numbers per year okay so if we take 20
of margins thirty percent of margins so
it's about a hundred million dollar
company he says yes he's gotta spend you
have to watch
i said yes i said so the same i said so
how many employees do you have he said
100 employees i said so i'm assuming
you've also given a percent of the
company to all your 100 employees
because that's when it means you're a
total socialist where you're being fair
with everybody who owns the entire
company i do
i said dan if you really are so
concerned about your employees
when do you plan on giving each of them
a percent
if you've never seen this interview i
gotta go you have to see this interview
he says i think you should go full
so so go one more step
you know don't just stop at 70. take a
percent and give it to everybody
well you know technically tax i can't
say no you can't do that i've done that
i did that myself i gave some shares to
my guys not 100 of them but i also don't
agree with you the fact that everybody
should make 70 grand i think some people
should make more money and some people
should make less money and somebody
should get fired to somebody so we get
promotions
so the point is you go on tick-tock
where the young people are to say huh oh
that does kind of make sense but i can't
agree with it that does kind of make
sense but i can't agree with it
that that does kind of make sense i
don't agree with it
[ __ ] i agree with too much stuff this
guy's saying damn this is not good yeah
because my professor i loved
he would have hated this guy and what
he's saying
but i'm starting to like what they're
saying yeah what is going on to me am i
like getting that's why i'm on tick tock
does that make sense yeah i'm working
money on tick tock like what's my am i
trying to go do a
video on tick tock to be famous no
that's not the strategy the is to get
these guys to be looking out there let's
see when we post this on tick tock if it
gets flat or community guys we're about
to find out about to learn a lot and
i'll keep you updated updated next
because i'm sure uh we are going to post
that on tick tock okay let's continue
next story do you guys want to go to the
trans uh yeah please skateboarder let's
go to that one right there or
even with trans uh which one you are
our friend
i don't know i mean that's all i wanted
let's go to the skateboarder first
because we have some skateboarder fans
so trans skateboarder who won first
prize against teen is a combat vet dad
who was rejected from the olympics okay
all right so let's see what the story is
29 year biological male who came in
first place at a new york women's
skateboarding competition is a father of
three and a combat veteran who was
previously rejected from the olympics
for having too much testosterone
is this this is not a joke though i
thought i wrote this as a comedy this is
not a so richie tres who also goes by
richie and tres won over
shiloh couturier 13 year old girl who
was ranked 133rd and the
border global ranks which are based on
performance and skateboarding
competitions trust by comparison sits at
8 38 and ranking trust took the top
title in the women's division at
of the border open taking on 500 i have
three kids i'm married
i did my time in the military i own a
company i've decided i like to being
pretty and cute
interested in an interview about
skateboarding last year so everything
that goes with that is female i love
female bodies i think it's a work of art
are you positive this is a true story
it's 100 percent of truth i thought this
is on fox news i thought he was trying
to can you
troll us but this is no that's real
that is real
listen sometimes you just want to be
pretty and cute jed you understand like
i don't want to beat the [ __ ] out of 13
year old girls that their dreams are
just crushed see this is where this
conversation has gone now now you have a
29 year old biological male
who is beating a 13 year old girl in
women's sports and we're all supposed to
sit swallow it and say oh this is the
new norm this is this is destructive
this has been uh a stain on women's
sports you now have a lot of female
athletes coming out and saying you know
they're afraid to talk they're afraid
that they're not
because they're afraid they're going to
be stigmatized they're afraid the second
they open their their mouth the media is
going to come in you know you're going
to have some article in cosmo magazine
about them and calling them a bigot and
you're anti-trans when in fact these are
girls who've worked their entire lives
they have struggled their entire lives
they've made sacrifices they've decided
not to party not to hang out with their
friends because they have a commitment
to sports they finally get to the top
and now they have to compete with a
grown man and no one's allowed to say
that it's a grown man so you have some
sports that are coming out now what was
the sport tyler we took we talked about
it the other day that came out i don't
know if you remember and said this isn't
going to fly
swimming right okay so swimming came out
which is you know antithetical to what's
going on in soccer finna but
right yeah but i love that picture with
the guy with the sweat with the ladies
right
this is this went from conversation i
talk about this on my show a lot because
this went from a conversation about
acceptance of like live the life you
want do what you want to do you're an
adult you're not hurting anyone else
you're not asking anyone else to pay for
whatever you're doing great we can
support you do what you want to do to
now
in if you don't endorse this absolute
psychosis that's going on look at the
images here look at this look at that
he's huge it's no no she's
it's a grown man he has still has his
testicles and his he has his male parts
well that's come on man that's that's
you guys but you just look at the
framework the difference
these women are clearly five two this
guy's six five yeah he's a swimmer and
you're supposed to say there's no advent
you know they came out a lot of a lot of
the swimmers the trans swimmers came out
said oh we don't have an advent you
don't have an advantage
come on we all have eyes and ears we
weren't born yesterday so what happens
to all the girls the actual women here
is is women's sports going to cease to
exist now think about it will it just be
men's sports and transports what's going
to happen here i'm serious it's a
serious question
i honestly think and i we talked about
this early before i walked into it there
should be
a league just a trans league word and
call it like
dicks i don't just put every listen
whatever you're confused whatever you
guys play over here leave these little
like dude this 13 year old girl you
realize she's gonna be like her father's
gonna have to sit her down and go listen
honey you're lost to a man grow a pair
literally like you're gonna have to get
some testosterone in you and cause like
it's dude it's cheating i don't care
what you say and you made a good point
nothing against that community good i
feel go do your thing but when it comes
to sports you're messing up people's
lives that little girl's that was her
that's her money yeah you don't get to
deprive you get to do what you want with
your own life but you don't get to
deprive somebody else of something based
on a new set of rules that you've now
demanded that we all endorse
that's not how it works let me tell you
why this skateboarding thing is it
probably won't get as much uh tabloid
time as this for whatever reason
the the these people are at least the
same age
whether they're they got you know
whatever private parts they got going on
they're all in college okay you're 18 to
22. i get it you're talking about a 29
year old person versus a 13 year old
girl yep yeah you're talking about that
is problematic in other language a
grown-ass man yes and a young girl yes
that's exactly right so pat you i mean
but you guys have kids what do you tell
your 13 year old i'm being dead serious
because i was trying to be funny what do
you tell your 13 year old daughter who
just beat up a big ass field of people
her age a 30 year old dude a 30 year old
veteran that wants to just be cute and
pretty and [ __ ] escape her words
honestly what are you two when your kid
gets very what do you think it's very
simple for me
um
one i go speak to whoever organized it
okay and i try to use my voice to create
change that's number one and i'm gonna
go recruit other people to also say do
you feel the same way we need to have a
meeting this is not acceptable if these
parents are not happy about it i'm not
alone we got more than 50 60 i think you
have to listen to what we have to say
beautiful then if they say no then i
have to look at other places where they
can compete fairly and i will go look at
it i'm not a helpless person i will find
solutions and i'll go to a different
place that's okay when so now imagine
now when you're putting your kids in a
competition you have to ask the question
just out of curiosity such and such area
when they compete they accept
transgender competitors and they don't
just go based on what the biological
situation is what's your protocols oh no
we don't accept that okay that's great
to know then i would like my kids to
fairly compete here and if they lose
they lose if they win they win no
problem and then if at that point you're
not happy because nobody around you has
the set of values and principles that
you do then you have to make a real
serious decision with your husband and
your wife and say we have to move to a
different place that matches our values
and principles it's that simple for me
yeah it's not that complicated what
would you tell the kid what would you
tell your kid though going to have a
conversation with the kid before and say
listen just oh we already have those
conversations because that conversation
is being had right now as we speak wow
and uh i'm straight up i explain to them
how science works i explained to them
how the values of parents and mothers
and fathers play environment values
principles confusion it's very easy to
get confused
and uh you know that's the conversation
it's a form of a bullying and in our
family we don't support bullying we're
good we don't support bullying we stand
up so good but i think i i think the the
approach is more from the standpoint of
you know when people were like i'm not
again rovi i can't believe what you're
doing
dude if you're so much for it
try to make change in the state you're
in if you can't move to another state i
agree what are you upset about
i didn't like california's policies when
it came down to supporting small
business owners i try to see if i can do
anything about it i may change i move to
texas and i move to another state do we
have somebody on here with us is she
ready or no if you want to okay
fantastic let's get right into it so
next story that we have is a story of
uh uh let me first introduce to you who
we have here with us sepi shine am i
saying it correctly sepi
i can't hear you guys can we make sure
we can hear sepi before
because i think sepi unmuted herself
maybe it's on our end eric again can we
sepia i'm assuming you're unmuted on the
zoom on your end right
okay so what you need to do she's
speaking i'm sure she's unmuted if you
go on your go on your zoom thing that
you have go to the audio on the to the
right of mute yep try it now uh eric if
you can com uh can you hear me now
yeah we have it unmuted over here all
right try it on muted
try it now
can you sepi can you say a few words
just to kind of hear
no i can't hear i'd love to hear because
of the story going on in west hollywood
so it could be one of those things
we are unmuted everything should be good
eric can you come in
can you hear me now oh yeah if we can
hear you fantastic okay yeah okay
so sepi uh i'll have i have the intro
here for you mayor pro temp of west
hollywood
uh west hollywood council member behind
the uh uh the defunder police movement
that you have i believe uh a story came
out which i think rob reached out to you
and i'll read the story to you and then
i'll let you comment on it and we'll
have some banter here
upscale west hollywood votes to defund
sheriff department even as crimes soars
to 137 percent
while savings will be used to fund 30
unarmed security ambassadors and a
russian arts festival now keep in mind
this is an article i'm reading so
forgive me if you don't agree with the
article let me just finish the article
here
uh papa papa here we go west oliver city
council has voted to defund the
sheriff's department despite crime
rocketing 137 percent
the proposal passed by narrow three to
two votes will see the current force of
around 60 sheriff deputies reduced by
four funds saved by reducing the head
count
will be used to pay for unarmed security
ambassadors under a scheme called block
by block despite slashing the police
policing budget the council agreed to
stump
up funds for russian arts festival
increasing their contribution from 14
000 to 50 000
and then lauren mester i believe if i'm
pronouncing it correctly democratic
mayor of west hollywood and a member of
the council who voted against the plan
called it illogical
noting that the los angeles enclave is
afflicted by rising tide of violence so
having said that seppi if i'm not
mistaken you were the leader in uh
causing this change yes if i'm not
mistaken
um so here's the thing um i made the
motion
and there's a lot of misinformation out
there about what we did what we actually
did monday night was go through and
approve our entire budget
what we did with regard to our community
safety department which has nothing to
do with the russian arts festival
that's a completely different budget
line item
we actually increased our public safety
department budget as a whole
we reallocated funding within the
department and increased public safety
funds this whole um wording about oh
they're defunding the police this is
actually not what the defund the police
movement was
um
supposed to be defunding the police
movement was about uh slashing
officers
and putting that money into social
services what we did do is on a
different budget item increase social
services by a million dollars but it had
nothing to do with this we have a proven
program called block by block security
ambassadors which by the way the mayor
herself brought forward two items to
increase their presence on our east side
which was having a lot of crime in
commercial corridors earlier this year
and that proved really successful and
then throughout the commercial corridors
in this same budget we increased six
kiosks for our businesses and 36
full-time block by block ambassadors so
it's really disappointing
that
she
supports this program for businesses but
when it comes to residents who want foot
patrols she thinks it's it's not
successful and that's just a rhetoric
she's using to get reelected frankly
excuse me
excuse me jedidiah here i just had a
question for you um you know because the
the original defund the police movement
the motivation was actually to
reallocate money but it was to remove
money from police and move it into other
aspects oftentimes people suggested
social workers
other options that were not so what i'm
trying to get to the bottom ups here i
don't know what a block by block
ambassador is here but ultimately you
have a problem in this area of
california with crime i think we can all
acknowledge that so is there going to be
money a that leaves the sheriff's
department that is going to cause less
police officers to be available to be on
the street and if so
what is the alternative to that are you
going to advocate for second amendment
rights for citizens
what is the alternative because safety
has to come from somewhere and if you
can't call the police what do you
do sure so here's the thing our
residents have wanted us to have foot
patrols in neighborhoods
and the
deputies in the sheriff's department
their
pay has increased substantially over the
past 10 years almost doubled is the foot
not to interrupt are the foot patrols
armed are those people going to be armed
as police officers would be no they are
not armed okay so
so what happens
there are block by block security
ambassadors that have proved successful
to deter crimes are they
are the security ambassadors armed no no
no no one is on okay so i have a
question for you though because the
criminals are armed
criminals are most of the time armed
with something so if a criminal has a
gun we know criminals don't obey laws
they get a gun they get a hold of a gun
they see they they they set out to cause
crime to rob assault whatever it may be
and they're not confronted with someone
who is armed what is that person going
to do get shot what what happens there
is that is that a are you how are you
envisioning that conversation because to
me
it seems that
someone who's trained someone who has
passed their background checks someone
who is a
a citizen who is armed or someone who is
a police officer would be the best
person for that criminal to meet on the
street not someone who's going to try to
talk them out of committing a crime i'm
curiously
yeah sure here's the thing we have
trained our block by block ambassadors
and crime doesn't just happen in an
isolated place in the city of west
hollywood it happens all over and we
have proven that these block by block
ambassadors actually determine deter
criminals we literally have proof of
that
um and right now
they have not been um
under harm doing their job they've been
doing a fantastic
in california look at the job rate in
the area right so
by the way if they're doing a great job
why does the crime rate look like it
does the 137 by the way is also
factually untrue that was a point in
time and literally um
the problem with percentages is you're
looking at something if if if there was
one robbery and then it became two over
six months that's a hundred percent
increase the fact is if you we looked at
all the numbers and all the stats of
crimes and
the
2019 numbers were actually higher than
2021. of course 2020 was low because
crime fell because people mostly were
locked into their homes um so these
these percentages um
really create more fear and they're
they're actually not based on what the
truth is and so the block by block
security ambassador is works in our
commercial corridors and it's going to
work in our residential and
we're doing this in a very pragmatic
slow way we're going to be decreasing
two deputies in 90 days and we actually
added one extra deputy so the net total
in 90 days will actually be one we've
had issues in our nightlife district at
night so we're adding one entertainment
policing deputy and then nine months
from now we're going to re-evaluate the
program happy canadian
we're going to see what the crime stats
are in nine months and in nine months if
the program is successful we may reduce
three more deputies and this is 60
deputies versus then 56 in total
potentially sepi can i a legitimate
question because i come from new york
city which struggles with crime as of
late it's one of the reasons i moved was
because i have a two and a half year old
and i couldn't justify living in a city
where the truly the police force didn't
feel supported and also second amendment
rights aren't exactly upheld for
individuals in new york city how do you
feel what do you say to someone like me
uh i'm a young woman i'm pretty small in
size and stature i like the idea of a
police force that feels supported and i
like the idea of a strong second
amendment because i know that if i'm met
on a street corner by someone who wants
to do harm to me or my child i want
someone i want i want the good guy with
the gun be it a police officer or myself
to be able to counter that person what
do you say to someone who hears this and
hears you know about ambassadors and
social workers and just doesn't feel
confident and comfortable living in a
city where that is the alternative and
the antithesis that's presented to a
criminal walking around with a gun who
seeks to do harm what do you say to me
first of all what i say to you is um i
understand your fear
i understand your fear um and honestly
as a woman um i myself uh
have had fears walking streets and what
i will also say is looking at the actual
crime stats
um
they're not as high as the media is
making them seen and spinning them but
it's not just a media game step because
i've been in i've been in weho and i've
been in new york city it's real it's
tangible it's on the ground so i mean do
you support the second amendment are you
a second amendment advocate if someone
wanted to go and follow the proper
protocol and they said this is my city
they're decreasing the police force this
is my opportunity to step in and defend
myself and my family would you support
that
uh defend yourself and your family in
what way yeah say i wanted to get a gun
say i wanted to follow protocol and i
said there's less police on the streets
i don't trust that i don't want to pick
up my phone and know that resources have
been cut and maybe there's a five-minute
delay on when that police officer
arrives because there's less of them
this is a decision being made say in
california so i want to go and i want to
get a gun to protect myself and my
family follow proper protocol pass that
you know the checks do you support that
listen
um we now live in a different america
with people being able to uh now carry
concealed weapons we don't california
has not analyzed what our laws are with
respect to no but i'm asking you i'm
asking you if you support is if someone
if someone um
under the law needs to defend themselves
then they can defend themselves and what
i would say to you just to finish up on
that is um we have tested this program
our residents have wanted foot patrols
in our residential streets and we are
giving them
30 boots on the ground and we're doing
it in a program pragmatic way which
brings public safety but also
slowly phases out literally actually the
total of one deputy in 90 days
that is
something that will give more public
safety to people and we're going to
monitor the program and see what happens
in nine months those people those people
better be prepared in my opinion to do
some combat i mean if you're telling me
those people go and train to be i mean
you're talking about boots on the ground
they better i mean are they kickboxing
experts because people who intend to
farm they're already on the top they're
already on the ground they're already on
the ground so we know that's what i'm
saying look at the crime yeah they're
already all over the city in the
commercial areas which actually have a
higher amount of crime than everywhere
else so they've already been tested and
um they've been successful i've actually
said this is vince no john here i
actually witnessed this firsthand i was
uh i was working doing stand-up
auditioning doing all my stuff working
security in north hollywood on magnolia
and lancaster which is all little
restaurants and and you know you know
little diners and you know it's really
it's popping coffee shops and all that
stuff and there was always i want to say
three or four because i was working
security the safety ambassadors that you
were speaking of that you know they were
the yellow shirts and no gun and they
and they patrol i did i personally
didn't see any
less crime i mean the fighting and
everything was still happening the only
thing that they were responding to from
where i was at was the homeless
situation like when homeless people were
starting to you know fight or argue or
you know they were doing drugs they were
called and there was instances where we
needed the cops called that's all that
they were doing was calling the cops for
us which we could have done ourselves
there was a guy that had a knife and i
was like oh my god the safety ambassador
does not get involved they just called
9-1-1 and i was like i could have done
exactly what you just did so i i'd be
interested to see if the the numbers do
change because at the end of the day the
cop was called and if we're getting less
cops and they're not getting motivated
to come help i don't i don't see how
that would help the the crime rate
we're in a partnership with the
sheriff's department um we're not
getting rid of them we're actually also
by the way looking at a feasibility
study to create our own municipal police
department too
what is the motivation if you don't mind
me asking what is the motivation to cut
you you know you emphasized oh it's only
one officer what is the motivation
behind the cut overall why do you want
to make that cut
sure fiscal responsibility because we
had to pass a budget
and
one
sheriff's deputy equals 4.6 block by
block ambassadors so it is it is
balancing a budget
and reallocating the funding to another
department that's an alternative it is
something new and i understand the fear
people have
when
people try new things and this is a new
alternative that is actually not new in
our city and by the way regarding north
hollywood i don't know about north
hollywood we're city of west hollywood
and our block by block program has
worked yeah i mean i agree with you on
fiscal responsibility you and i can
agree on that point i'm a fiscal
responsibility girl i'm somebody who
look you know you should line item but
look at that budget see what cut what
you can but i'm just going to say to you
that
it's not realistic in my opinion to if
you're going to go for fiscal
responsibility the last area you should
be looking at in a place that does have
exponentially high crime is cutting the
police force it seems to me that there
must be some political motivation
involved here there was political
motivation involved in the defund the
police movement at large and i'm just
i'm just going to put a warning out
there that
if you throw out i don't care if it's a
social worker i don't care who it is if
they're unarmed and they're just going
to seek to keep the peace it's an
admirable goal it's an admirable gesture
but if they are faced with people who
intend to do harm who are armed that's
going to be a problem and there are
going to be families moms dads that are
going to take one look around at that
and they're going to say i need to take
this job on to myself if there's not
going to be an active police officer to
do what they can and should be doing in
this space so i would not be surprised
if you see people going and get
registering for their gun licenses and
seeing news stories like this in in
places like uh you know weho or wherever
it may be new york city i've seen it
happen in new york city already and you
see you know citizens feeling like they
need to now do the job the police
officers should be doing because they're
concerned that a defund the police
movement isn't prioritizing safety
that's just my opinion we are limited to
time you got one minute i just want to
throw out an idea hopefully sepi's open
to it our friend vince right here he
just moved here from la california the
next time you're there yes are you
willing to go along with the yellow
shirt 100 crew the 30 of them and just
see what's going on let's get some
tangerines
are you able to do that separately
is he able to do that
i am happy to connect you with our block
by block there it is
and is there any way we can go find the
good golden sea place anywhere
and that's what go to the subsidy
listen i wish there was a persian
restaurant there isn't anything the only
one is wrong
there's one right outside there's and
there's plenty all around we'd have to
go to raffi
appreciate you for coming out and taking
the questions we respect that a lot and
we look forward to following up with you
folks of west hollywood are watching
this if it works my suggestion is tell
the world about it on twitter and if it
doesn't work i also suggest tell the
world about it on twitter and youtube so
we can all see if this is something
other cities should consider as well
sepi have a great day thank you again
for coming on thank you thanks everyone
fantastic okay
uh all right by the way for me again the
fact that she said yes to beyond last
second good for her come and give your
argument you're faced off with
a respectful jedediah who will push but
you'll respect and then the audience can
make a decision for themselves that to
me is what a great
exchange is and you decide and and
admitted on camera that she is a fiscal
conservative i am a fiscal i appreciate
that just it's not just your own
household from your end from your rent
from your rent yes sir do you think
that'll work
uh there's so much minutia right there i
like i like the fact that she said in
nine months we're gonna revisit this she
did not seem crazy lunatic fringe i
don't as a person i don't know about her
policies she seemed actually pretty
reasonable
i don't get involved in west hollywood
politics that's not my thing but let's
see what happens you're absolutely right
if it works tell the world about it but
if it doesn't work you also deserve the
right to tell the world about it and
then we'll see what happened there okay
yeah all right sounds good gang today we
had a good time a couple things i didn't
want to tell you guys let me give a
couple shout out to some folks here
today uh who were on the podcast uh
one uh scott rodriguez we already did
two
we had gilman uh mammon who said i'm a
long island jew i work in the city
anyone who has the means and isn't tie
down is moving to florida bloomberg once
said bloomberg once said
living in new york is a luxury what a
statement to make living in new york is
a luxury you have to be able to afford
it uh uh mr uh barefoot blue jean what a
name gave 20 bucks and said please get
pierre poliviere the next lead of the
conservative party and the next pm of
canada on the show we've invited him but
if you have contacts let him know we'd
love to have him on victor thank you
uh dr saint gave a hundred dollars and
said also watch too big to fail great
show
pat tell me you went to airborne school
if not i guess we can be perfect lol
thank you for your service brother thank
you for yours as well i went aerosol not
airborne jonathan fuentes gave 10 bucks
and i said i'm 30 years old married with
a one-year-old we make 150 a year in
california bay area with the recession
starting tomorrow what what what must we
do right make more money
is what you got it then we had a bunch
of guys that became insiders uh alex i
will see you at sls uh dr saint uh
congratulations uh 24 bitcoin oh you
guys talk about bitcoin we didn't get
into bitcoin maybe we will next time and
a bunch of folks became members today
let me give a quick shout out to the new
members we got here matthew chris is
crypto trends 101 scott rodriguez
upgraded to insider allen hopkins leo
cannell andre pascu john butler kevin
northcutt a a eddie gomez michael
peterson and m1
welcome to the uh
uh the membership on the podcast uh also
a quick shout out to uh the couple
that is uh uh just got proposed they're
about to get married i believe his name
is matt but i do know his fiance's name
is rachel finale shout out to you guys
enjoy the photo shoot and wishing you
guys nothing but the very best folks
happy fourth of july don't miss
jedediah's podcast
don't miss valuetainment comedy
subscribe to valuetainment we have a
bunch of stuff coming out guys
yesterday with the italian news if you
haven't seen it i got so many text
messages and obviously adam's got some
podcasts
have a great weekend everyone bye bye
bye bye bye
you